how does shoot a Jason Bourne action
scenes lots and lots of inserts
everything is edgelet and everything is
shaky and everything at slow shutter
speed everything is very open aperture
I'm going to show you how to get the
Jason Bourne Hollywood look for your
video step 1
Jason Bourne has a bit of a low-key look
it's a little bit darker a little bit
dimmer so the very first thing I'm going
to do is turn off all the lights in here
now it's really dark it's the very next
thing we need to do is turn on our fill
light the next thing we need to do is
turn on our edge lights there we have it
the edge light needs to be positioned
behind the actor if it gets too far to
the side of the person or in front of
them it just kind of becomes a key or
fill and does not look very good it must
be a niche one light that's warm is that
a tungsten temperature and one light
that's cold daylight temperature with my
camera is a white balance set to
tungsten his skin will look normal and
the light coming from that warm light
will look white to light coming from
that daylight light and a really turned
blue change my white balance thirty six
hundred degrees Kelvin
so the Tungsten's will still be just a
touch orange but pretty close to white
in those daylight edges it's going to
look blue step one is to put some point
lights in your scene these lights should
be warm to match the fill in Jason
Bourne space they're not to light the
room but to give you little spots of
interest in the distance that's there on
the wall step two is then just bring the
rest of the room up a little bit in
brightest with a daylight colored light
I have it pointed up not at the
character the scene what's happening
here is this light that's hitting the
top of the ceiling and it's diffusing
and then bouncing back down everywhere
it's getting us a very soft blue globe
there's not a lot of direction there's
not a lot of shadow either it's very
very soft all right so now our lights
are set up to film we need to set up our
camera aperture and shutter speed you
want to get as soft of a background as
possible with your camera you're going
to want to open your aperture pretty
much as far as you can the shutter speed
needs to be set to 1 over 48 if you're
shooting at 24 frames per second 1 over
60 if you're shooting at 30 because
Jason Bourne does not have Kris movement
as very blurry motion blurred movement
you get that by having your shutter open
longer
oh the bad guy that says hey let's get
another action shot Oh rolling and
actually wait wait wait
wait a minute that doesn't look very
good because that edge light when I
moved over here became your fill light
because coming from the direction of the
camera leading with that edge wipe
always be behind my actor I'm moving the
camera when you keep the actor between
camera and the edge light I'm going to
move this Phil like stay on his face I
actually don't care that much about
continuity anyone is wondering we are
using aperture lights this is the after
120 T it is a little point light LED and
a little big dish looks great these are
the aperture light storms they're
basically large LED light arrays they
give off a very nice area life they're
all battery-powered we are running them
all off of Anton powered batteries right
now I'm giving this down here and
shyness to this railing get some shadows
up in that wall it's a couple warm
streaks of light the rest it's still
filled in at this cool daylight light
and I'm gonna get my second shot imagine
you heard a sound coming from that door
so I want you to sneak forwards
shooting with a more telephoto lens kind
of compresses the space and also makes
things look a little bit more composed
foreground mid-ground background put
something in the foreground here to
shoot through the stuff on the kitchen
counter these lenses for example
mid-ground be mister bjorn back gonna do
that painting light on the hall
lights off downstairs ago because the
second step happens on my computer he's
making Thanksgiving it's that simple I
have my shots just important to the
timeline the movements nice I mean it's
got that Jason Bourne shakiness focus is
dynamic really isolating or we should be
looking now I know not everybody has
premiere what I'm doing here can
generally be done on any program if you
know what filters singers talk about
just mullerian next thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to apply a crop filter
that adjustment layer crop can let you
crop off the tops and bottoms of your
image give you those widescreen bars
boom widescreen bars or everything looks
great another way you can get that
widescreen looks to actually change your
sequence settings so here thirty and
forty by sixteen twenty
all right the next step is to apply the
metrics we're going to get that film up
now that Jason Bourne stylized in life
I'm going to go to my effect controls
under creative is an option to apply a
look and I'm going to apply the m31
lookup table this lookup table it does
cost money it's not that expensive you
can get it part as part of the Osiris
look-up tables pack from color grading
central.com
they're amazing I've used them for years
it's the best $50 you are spend to make
your footage look good it works on
iphone footage or some DSLR footage it
works on red footage it works on
everything it looks cool but doesn't
quite look like Jason Bourne Nick's a
little orange things a little blue it's
because Jason Bourne look is shift a
little bit more towards the yellows so
now I'm going to go down to my shadow
tint to my highlight s did my highlights
a little more yellow and I'm going to
shift my shadows next up I'm going to
bump up the vibrance and saturation
basically just enhancing the colors a
little bit so you can mess around the
color more if you want to it's very easy
to take color wheels and stylize things
some of those scenes in Jason Bourne are
actually overall very warm some of these
things are overall very cool so the m31
lookup table with this lighting setup
then with some tweaks cab dialed in to
the look of your camera will give you a
very cinematic look that looks a lot
like a Jason Bourne movie so hope you
guys learn something I hope you guys
enjoyed watching this process to see how
we got this away and yeah do some more
stuff like this in the future
you